as you know we inherited a tough
situation
i've looked at a a system where um
people have been housed in inhumane
conditions over the last
many years an asylum system that has
been broken
and that needs to be reconstructed and
in five months we've made progress but
there's still much more work to be done
but we've made progress
okay vice president harris last week
blamed the trump administration for the
border crisis during her visit to el
paso
meanwhile hhs secretary becerra will
head to fort
bliss migrant facility today as
troubling reports reveal minors
there are on suicide watch after being
exposed to disease and abuse
here to react former acting dhs
secretary and heritage
foundation visiting fellow chad wolfe
chad good morning
good morning you know it's interesting
kamala harris last thursday
went to el paso and she actually was
within about a mile or so
of the place that mr basara is going to
visit today but she didn't go to that
place because that place
is not the kind of image the
administration really wants
well i think that's right i would
characterize vice president harris's
trip to el paso as a missed opportunity
on a variety of different fronts she
certainly could have visited fort bliss
but she also could have actually gone to
the
to the epicenter of the migrant crisis
that we see today and that's an rgv
about 800 miles away from el paso
she could have gone to detention
facilities she could have gone to donna
the donna facility down there which is
where the vast majority
of these migrants are being housed and
processed she didn't do any of that
instead she went to a
legal port of entry right where we know
this is not where the crisis is
occurring folks are not coming across
illegally
they're coming across illegally and so
she really didn't get a sense of what
was going on
and able to talk to the to the agents
there actually apprehending
these folks on a nightly basis so
overall missed opportunity
uh i would say well but the
administration
had to do something because when you
look at their polling numbers and
they're looking at the poll numbers 24
7 do you approve or disapprove of the
way
the biden administration is handling
immigration a majority of americans
disapprove of what they're doing and you
know you couple that with crime which
also uh more people disapprove of and
chad
they've got some problems and that's why
she went and checked the box last week
because she was even getting questions
from
nbc's lester holt about you know when
are you going to visit the
the southern border and she said i've
already been there and he said no you
haven't
so she had to go she went didn't really
do much you say
yeah that's exactly right and she
continues to spread misinformation
talking about how they inherited
a difficult problem from the last
administration that's simply not the
case what they did inherit
was a secure border and they inherited a
network of policies
and procedures that we gave them to keep
that border secure
a variety of different options to choose
from as they
try to secure that border and enforce
immigration law and what we know is on
inauguration day they threw all of that
out
and that's the result of the crisis that
we're seeing today over 183 000 illegal
apprehensions in one month alone the
last month
and we're likely going to see those
numbers uh continue throughout the
summer so
she's not being honest uh and we
continue to see this misinformation
spread
well but you know secretary marcus is
saying that the strategy is working
so if you've got close to two hundred
thousand people coming across the border
illegally
what is the strategy
well it's very difficult to uh to
ascertain
when they talk about progress being made
on the border all i can see is the
progress
moving migrant children or i should say
teenagers
from border patrol facilities to hhs
facilities and so you're simply moving
them from one government facility to
another
i'm not sure that that's really progress
that's not progress on actually trying
to solve
the crisis trying to stop the illegal
behavior they're simply trying to manage
the crisis
instead of actually putting procedures
and programs in place to stop the crisis
and i think that's pretty evident to the
american people and those that are
reflected in the in the poll numbers
that you show there
i think you're right they're upside down
all right chad wolfe thank you very much
sir for joining us live today from dc
all right thank you